それでは じゃあよろしくお願いします
何番目でしたっけ？今日は
はい では始まりま
す アッパマッドーパマッテスー スッテスーバフジャーガロー アバラッサングシーガッソー ヒットゥワーヤーティ スメ
ーダッソー アッパマッドーパマッテスー スッテスーバフジャーガロー アバラッサングシーガッソー ヒットゥワーヤーティ スメーダッソー
で その偈の意味はアッパマッドー
放逸でない人 いわゆるしっかりと努力
頑張る人っていう意味なんですね
パマッテスー 怠って放逸して怠けて
やるべきことをやらないで放棄している人々をですね
番目の言葉 それでアッパマッドーは主語ですからね
パマッテスーっていうのは
この怠っている人々の中でアッパマッドー
怠らない人がということ
次のフレーズはスッテスーバフジャーガロー
スッテスー 寝ている人々の中でバフジャーガロー
もうたくさんこの起きている人
ジャーグラっていうのは夜徹夜するという意味なんですね
寝ないで頑張る人がですね
アバラッサングシーガッソー
次のフレーズ アバラッサン
すごく力がない弱々しい馬ですね
シーガッソー その弱々しい馬たちの中でシーガッソー
足が速い馬のようにになるんです
ヒットゥワーヤーティ
追い越して先へ行くんだと
スメーダッソー 智慧のある人が
なんかもうそんなに意味まとめないかもしれませんですけど
智慧のある人が いわゆる賢者は怠らないでやるべきことはやるんですと
それで他の人々はまあずっと怠っている
それから他の人々はよくちゃんと寝ているんですけど
賢者は徹夜して寝ないでちゃんとやるべき仕事はする
そうすると 弱々しい馬たちの中で足の速い馬がサッと走って勝つような感じで
賢者は人生に勝ちますよということなんです
そういう訳を見ると ああ
なんだ 単純な意味ではないかということは
まあだと思うかもしれません
単純な意味で取っても決して構いません
やるべきことをやらない人が
まあ足がボロボロ馬と一緒に競争するような感じで
まあ勝てるわけじゃないんだと
だから いかなる場合でも成功したいと思うならば
人生の場合は人生を成功したいと思うならば
やっぱりやるべきことは淡々とやらなくちゃいけない
で そうやってそういう風にこの一般的な知識でも解説というのはできます
できるように お釈迦様が真理を語るんです
しかし お釈迦様が言っていることは
世間でも誰でも知っている単純明快なことでもないんです
普通 ちゃんと頑張らないとダメですよというぐらいの意味なんですよ
これぐらいは誰にでも言えますよ
お釈迦様がね それぐらいのことを言うならばね
どうったことはないんですよ
仏教も しっかりと頑張らなきゃダメだよと
負けますよと というぐらいだったらね
それだけ言ってるわけじゃないんです
しかし 真理はどちらにでも真理っていうのは法則ですから当てはめるんですよ
子供の時から年寄りになるまで
人生にも当てはまるし
真理のブッダの修行の世界にも同じ真理が当てはめますよ
やるべきことをやらないとはもうダメということはどこにでも通じる真理なんです
それはどういうことかともうちょっと考えた方がいいんです
で やるべきことをやらないで後回しにするというね
ことは世の中でよくあります
まあ後でやりますと 今はその気分じゃないんですね
今はそのやる気分じゃないんだから
じゃあ後でやりますということにしてしまうんです
それがどういうことでしょうかと
普通は自分の気分で生きていて
何かうまいことをできるということではありません
この世の中で それはなかなか人が気づかないんですよ
自分の気持ちに正直に生きていられることはすごく幸せやと思ってるんです
でも事実は逆なんです
自分の気持ちに正直に生きていても
人生はダメになるんです
では 自分の気持ちをごまかしてインチキできていればよろしいですかね
だったら それもダメなんです
それよくやってますよ
自分の気持ちは考え方はね
言いたいことはね なんか強引に抑えておいて
別な顔をして生きてみるということはよくやってるでしょうに
それでもいいわけじゃないんです
そういうあの建前と本音っていうものを激しく違うものを極端的に違うものを持っていて
本音は見せようとも出そうともしないで
建前だけで一生懸命頑張るというのは
それも世の中でやっている
そういうことをやっているんだから思うんですよ
やっぱり自分の正直な気持ちで生きていられれば幸せだろうと
こちらで言っているのは
その２つも間違っているということなんです
ではどうすればいいかと
私たちの正直な気持ち
ですかと勉強しなくちゃいけないんですよ
正直な気持ち 正直な気持ちと言うんですが
それが何なのかと はっきりとくっきりと明確に表面に出してもらわないと答えが出てこない
決してこの世間の人間は
自分の正直な気持ちは何なのかと見ようとしないんですよ
見ようともしないで 正直な気持ちで生きていきたいというのは
もうちょっとおかしい話なんです
変な話なんです だから
正直な気持ちで生きていて良いか悪いか決める前に
あなたの正直な気持ちって何なのかと
あなたはどうでもいいんです
私の正直な気持ちって何なのかと
自分の心にある気持ちをはっきりと明確に自分で表面化しなくちゃいけないんですよ
無意識でごちゃごちゃところで
曖昧なところでもう置いておいてはいけないんです
それで自分の本当の気持ちというものは
表面化して意識化して
これだとはっきりとわかる場合は
これに従って良いか悪いかということはいとも簡単にわかるんですよ
で そういうところはお釈迦様が言いたがっている
教えたがっているところなんです
それで何のために瞑想は推薦しているかと
お釈迦様はヴィパッサナー瞑想という観察瞑想を覚りの道であるということで
たった一つしかないんだよというふうに推薦しているんです
この観察することで 自分の気持ちというものははっきりと意識化するんです
自分は何者かと ヴィパッサナーを実践してみると見えてくるはずなんです
そんなに難しいことでもないんです
すごく簡単なことです
それで見えてくる自分
その自分にの気分 気持ちに従うべきかないかということは
すぐ自動的に判断できます
それで 結局 仏教はお釈迦様が無数の数えられないほどの人々の心の働きをね
すべてチェックしてチェックして
そこで普遍的な法則を次から次へと作っているんです
人間の正直な気持ちっていうのは
一番元に元にある土台になっているのは無知ということなんです
無明 無知ということ その無知の上で
さらに欲と怒りと無知というまた同じものなんですけど
成り立っているんです
無知は回出てくるんです
土台になっている無知はなかなか表面には出てこないんです
我々は表面的に知っているところは欲は知ってますね
怒りも知ってます 無知というものはそれなりに知ってます
アホじゃないかと自分にも言うでしょうね
なんで私はバカなことをやっているんでしょうかと
自分を叱ったりもするでしょうね
その場合は無知ですけど
自分の無知に怒っているんですね
で それは表面に見える無知です
欲と同じです 何か欲しくなったら欲しいという気持ちはわかるんです
なんか変なバカなことをやっている
自分がバカなことをやっているとわかっているんです
しかし この土台になっている無知は
それは表面化はしないんです
だから土台になっている無知には無明というんですね
無知というよりもアヴィッジャというね
パーリの言葉使っているんです
貪瞋痴の無知にはモハというね
言葉使ってます そんなに差がないんだけど
モハ 無知といえばほとんどわかっているもんです
経験しているんです 我々は欲も経験しているし
怒りも経験しているし
無知 バカなことも経験しているんですよ
何かやりたいんだけど
何かしたいんだけど どうももうその気にならないとかね
本を読みたいんだけど
読んでいるんだけど なかなか頭に入らないとかね
そうやっていろいろ頭が動いてくれない経験っていうのは
出した答えはもうまるっきり間違ったとかね
そういう無知の経験もよくあります
卒中 怒りの経験もありますし
欲の経験もありますし
無知のおらかな経験もありますからね
その分かってる無知にはもう他というんです
しかし 毛髪の同じ毛髪にもわからない
表面化しない土台として無明というものは働くんですね
それで一応そこで覚えてください
もう無明という土台があって
無知でもいいんです 無知という土台があって
その上で建物を建ててます
3つ 欲と怒りと無知と建てたものは見えます
土台は見えません 建物は見えるでしょう
でも我々にはこの建物の土台は見えません
で 下にやっている工事は見えません
しかし 建物よりもしっかりできているのはそこら辺なんです
大体建物を作る場合は
まず下の工事はしっかりやるんですよ
厚いコンクリートをね
もうつけて もうそれですごい丁寧に作って
その上もうほんのちょっともうシロアリにでも食えれるぐらいのもう木材持ってきて
あっちこっちあっちこっち引っ張って
もう二階建物三階建物を作る
一旦作って もうシート張って
もう壁紙張っていろいろしたら
もうすごい立派な建物で見えますけど
でもそれよりすごい強くてしっかりとできているのは
あの地か潜っている土台なんです Foundation
なんです 建物はもう台風で潰れたっても Foundation
のはそのままなんです
基礎 それはそのままなんです
壊れません あんなに頑固で頑丈でしっかりしているのに
これはもう認識はしません
気にもしません 我々は建物の中に入って
すごく気持ちよく生活しているだけ
で それが心の中の法則にも同じ似ている感じで
無知という基礎があって
それはしっかりできています
なかなか台風に倒れるものじゃないんです
その上で欲と怒りと無知というものあるんです
その上にできている欲
怒りは卒中変わるんですよ
簡単に変わるんです 何か欲しい欲しいと思っていても
もうなんとかその人を説得させて
もうそこは 心気持ち変えることはできます
誰かと喧嘩して怒ってても
また話し合って なんとかなんとかして
また仲直りすることはできます
それで その怒りが消えているんです
何かバカなことをやらせたとしても
もう本当に教えてあげると
これはこういうことで
あまりいいことじゃないんだよと
あ そうですか と それでわかって
その無知がなくなることもあります
だから 表面に認識できる欲と怒りと無知っていうのは
そっちを変るんです 変えることもできます
でも基礎があるんだから
また組み上げてくるんです
いくら変えても終わりなく貪瞋痴が現れてくるんです
あの基礎がある限りは
その貪瞋痴っていうのは基礎があって
外の世界からもうごく一般単純つまらない情報が触れるんですよ
情報が触れた途端 あの基礎の無明からサッと怒りか欲か無知か
もういろいろ新しい幻想
現象 建物作るんです 次から次へと
だから我々はずっと情報に触れているんです
情報に触れているたびに
怒りか欲か無知か どちらかずっと現れっぱなしなんです
終わりがないんです それでヴィパッサナー瞑想させる場合は
耳に何か音なんか入ったら音だと言いなさいよと
救急車とかあれやこれやとか言ったらアカンと
いうのは何だのかと それが体に触れるこの本当の情報
認識しておきなさい それをずっと音
音 音だと これは時計の音やとわかっていても
音 音という救急車の音だとわかっていても
音 音と確認する 消防車とわかっていても
音 音と確認する あれはカラスの鳴き声やとわかっていても
音だと確認する やがてすべて音だと
やがてはもうないんですけど
すぐわかる人には瞬時にわかります
なんだ音でしょうということ
で わかった瞬間で 音に対して自分が現象化すること見えてくるんですよ
その音はカラスの音やと認識して
それからそれに対する怒りか欲か無知か何か作る
ただの音なのに だからそれたったの音ですよ
科学的に言えばもう厳密に音という振動だけ
そちらに音楽も何もうるさい音でも何もないんです
耳に触れた音は音楽にするか
うるさい雑音にするかっていうことは
その個人の勝手なんです
音楽だと認識した時点で欲が現れて
欲という建物が現れてくる
雑音だと 騒音だと認識しちゃうと
怒りが現れてくる あるいは無知が現れてくる
そうやって耳に触れる音という情報についても
いろいろ建物は作っているんですよ
だから認識することによって
例えば欲の建物を作る場合も
建物がいろいろあるでしょう
世の中で 無数にあるんです
そのように我々も欲の形は無数にあるんですよ
欲といえば一つのもう建築的な建物というわけじゃないんです
無数にあるんです で バラの花を見て欲が生まれる
桜の花を見て欲が生まれる
同じじゃないんですよ
その感情が 花束を見て気持ちが良くなる
それなりに作る欲の形が変わるんです
そういうことをなんとか理解した方が役に立つとは思います
それで 私は私たちの心ってどういうものかというと
この情報にそのまんま放棄させてるんですね
入りたい放題 耳から目から鼻から口から
でも全然管理はしてない
整理整頓しない 入る情報
だからこの嵐のように
ものすごいもう嵐のように心に情報はものすごいもう振れますね
絶えず情報の攻撃があるんです
それで心は絶えず貪瞋痴の現象がすーっと作っているんです
で 変わるんで 例えば人があの展覧会なんかに行って
絵を見て楽しむと 入った瞬間で
建物を見て この雰囲気を見て
ああ気持ちいいという風になります
それは欲でしょ そこで入る
入って最初の作品を見る
それでまた気持ちはいいんです
建物の雰囲気を見て 楽しい気分いいということはもうとっくに消えてるんです
違う欲が現れてるんです
1番目の作品を見ると
ああ これはなかなか綺麗だなと
それで2番目の作品を見る
そうするとまた雰囲気
気持ちが変わる 別な欲なんです
だからこの欲も次から次へと変わるんです
キリがなく その中でも個人的に
その中である一つの作品
作品にはくぎづけになったりもする
これはすごい これが気に入ったと
例えば 8番目の作品に自分がくぎづけになったならば
それから４０ ５０点あるかもしれませんよ
見えなくなっちゃうんです
あれを見て感動して それを頭で残しておいて
他のものをさーっとただ見るだけで
あ これ見 あ これ見 これ見
これはあまり面白いからという感じで終わって
その展覧会を出る 出てもあのインパクト強く
自分がくぎづけになった欲があの建物はまだまだ残っているんです
結構鉄筋コンクリート作っているんで
その場合は そこでもう情報触れないんですよ
情報触れないんだけど
その建物が結構きつく頑丈で
まぁあの無知の土台の上に乗っているんです
そういうものはさらにインパクトになって
無知の基礎に 次の建物を作る時は形変えるんです
[背景音楽]で そういう感じで
我々はまあ絶えず欲の現象を作ったり
怒りの現象を作ったり
無知の現象を作ったりしています
なぜかというと この基礎はもう全然変わりません
この基礎から現れるんです
現れるためには外から情報が必要なんです
外から情報がない場合はどうなるかというと
基礎にはいっぱいインパクトがものすごく溜まってるんだから
そこで勝手に作るんです
建物は 外になくても それはもう頭だけの回転です
頭で妄想しては もう怒ったり
欲を作ったり 無知を作ったりする
そこで絶えず頭の中の勝手に回転している
情報がない場合は 人は貪瞋痴がないかというととんでもないんです
もっと明確に作る 情報が入る場合はいくらか管理されてますよ
美しい人を見たら もうなんて美しいですかと思わないんです
その入る情報に合わせて
ああ 美しいですね 綺麗ですというふうに思うだけなんです
そこはインパクトになってくると
家に帰ってから妄想しちゃうと
もうキリがなく管理なく貪瞋痴が生まれてくる
だからこのパソコンやらコンピューターゲームやらいろいろやっていて
怒りやら憎しみ作るでしょ？あれは恐ろしいんです
子供同士で喧嘩して怒ったっても
それはそんなに恐ろしくないんです
限りなく怒りは現れてこないんです
情報に沿って現れるものだから
だから妄想だけの世界で怒り憎しみ出てくると
これ管理できないほど恐ろしくなって精神的にイカれてしまうんです
僕はあんまりそういうこのサイバー的なゲームやら遊びやらね
この芸術の世界やらね
あまり評価しないんです
これは精神的なイカれてしまう原因になるから
芸術でもその鑑賞する場合は
あの 限りなく怒り憎しみよく現れるわけじゃないんです
情報あるんだからね で
妄想することになると
もう明らかに精神的な異常です
でもそれも原因なく現れるわけじゃなくて
過去の情報から心に刻まれたインパクトあって
そこから新しく作るんです
新しく作ったもので 何回作っちゃえばもう消えるはずなんですけど
妄想で貪瞋痴作れば作るほど
また新しい新しいインパクトが心に刻むんですよ
だからこれ終わらないんです
こういうふうに考えれば
何かすごい感動的なものを見てしまった
釘付けになっちゃったと
心にすごいインパクトが残りましたと
それを二日三日考えたところで
じわじわと消えてしまうならば
別に問題ないんです いくらか考えて考えてね
例えば映画を見て 二日三日間それ考えたりして喜んでいたと
それでゆっくりと忘れてしまう
それはそんなに問題はありません
しかし 私たちはこの貪瞋痴の場合はそうならないんですね
例えば そうやって 何かのことで怒ったりする
それで後でまた考えると
また怒る また怒って またインパクトを作る
それでさらにまた怒って
またインパクトを作る
それで無限大に一つの出来事
その人を怒ることにすることはできます
それがみんなの心に常に起きている働きなんです
その中でさらに法則いろいろあります
このいいことだったら見事に消えちゃうんです
二 三回思い出したところで
もう面白くなくなっちゃって消えてしまうんです
悪いことは全然消えません
いつでも思い出して新しくするんです
怒り 憎しみ 無知っていうのは
再現するんです 再現して前と同じインパクト
この現場で起きたインパクトと全く同じインパクトか
よりさらに強いインパクトが作るんです
心はいつでもそうやって都合の悪い方向に動くんです
例えば 優しい気持ちになりましたとかね
人を助けてあげてすごくいい気分になったとかね
そういうことっていうのは
もう二 三回思い出してからもう忘れちゃうんです
悪いことはそうならないんです
さて 悪循環に回るようになってるんです
どんな人の心も これ不公平でしょ
いいことを何か思い出して
すごくインパクト付いたならば
それはずっと考えれば考えるほどどんどん強化していくならば本当にいいんですけど
なんでそうならないかというと
基礎が無知だから無明だからなんです
基礎が無明だから たまたま良い感情
貪瞋痴でない優しさとかね
知恵とか お布施とか 何か人にしてあげる気分とかね
そういうものはたまたま現れても
あまり基礎とは関係ないんですよ
基礎から自然に現れたものじゃないんです
あの基礎の上にただ置いただけのものなんです
貪瞋痴はそうじゃなくて
きちんとボルトで基礎ときっちりと繋げているものなんです
だから良いものっていうのは
何か置物のようにあの基礎の上に置いてあるものだから
もうそのうちなくなってしまうんです
これがすごく人間にとっては不幸なことなんですよ
でもどうすることもできない
心の基礎は無明です で
無明の上で貪瞋痴という数えられないほどの建物を作るんです
で なんで貪瞋痴三つにしたというと
この一つ一つに言葉をつけちゃうと言葉がないんですよ
だから三つに 三つのカテゴリに入れているんです
その方が理解しやすい
しかし実際は一本のお花を見て楽しむことと
綺麗に立てた花を見て楽しむことっていうのは同じではありません
それを理解してほしい
展覧会で絵画を見て楽しむ時は同じ喜びってわけじゃないんです
見る見る作品によって心に現れる喜びがそれぞれ違うんです
だから欲の数っていうのは無数
怒りの数も無数 無知の数も無数ですけど
そんな一つ一つに言葉を入れていったっても
これはもうできる話 ことじゃないんです
だからできるだけ全部categorize categorize
分析して分析して 仏教っていうのはものすごい苦労していますよ
人間に分かりやすくしてあげようと思って
これほど知識的に努力っていうのは
世界でどこでも誰でもやってないんです
だから 手にねじって覚えられるぐらい単純にグループ化して整理整頓して仏教は真理を教えているんです
言葉で言えば 皆様知って欲の場合は
本当に一つに分けてます
怒りだけはいくつかに分けてます
例えば 憎しみと嫉妬 落ち込みとか後悔とかね
これぐらいに分けてます
無知は２つかな 懐疑的な感情と混乱状態
なんか興奮状態 混乱状態
浮つきていうんでしたっけ
普通の日本語で何といいますか
浮つきなんとかいう言葉があるでしょ
うん うわつき うわつき状態と懐疑的な状態２つに分けてます
その２つで理解できます
無知ということは だから
このそういう風にこの無数のもの
とにかく似ているものはまとめてまとめてまとめてまとめて極端に似ているものをまとめてまとめていくつかにしているんです
それで最終的には貪瞋痴にしているんです
貪瞋痴にしてくれたところで
あ なんだ 単純かと思ってもね
単純なことをおっしゃってるわけじゃないんです
それがこの人間にはもう理解できるように
もう信じられないほどの努力の結果なんです
だから今も私にさえも考えられない
どうやってこういう風に分析して
もう組み合わせなんかはね
考えたんでしょうかと
そういうことで 次にわかってほしいものは
無明という基礎があって
その上で一時的な貪瞋痴がすーっと現れていって
それで基礎も変わるんですよ
基礎にずっとインパクト
エネルギーが入りますから
基礎もいつでも同じわけじゃないんです
基礎もそれなりにそれなりに変わってはいくんです
それで出てくるのはやっぱりどんなことでもこの瞬間だけですよ
人生は 次へ次へ次へとまた別なものに変わっていくんです
時間には停止っていうものはないんでしょ
我々は時間の上に生きているんです
時間というのは概念だけですけど
その上に生きているんです
ものはずっと絶えず変化しているんです
だから 後でしますということは成り立たないんです
何一つも後ですることはできません
それが人間理解していないんです
後でやりますと思うんです
そう思ってしまうのはしょうがないんですけど
例えば皿は後で洗いましょうとということを考えちゃうと
もう後で洗ったってもいいかもしれませんよ
そういうことで錯覚して
何でも後でできますと
でも何一つも後でできません
リセットもできません
時間は流れている 皿は別に壊れるわけじゃないんだから
今洗ってもよろしいし
夜洗ってもよろしいし
もう明日やってもいいんだけど
しかし その洗う時間によって
やっぱりそれでも変わっているんですよ
だから いかなるものでも今やらなくてはいけないということが仏教の真理なんです
今やるべきことをやらないで後回しにして
後でやる時も その人はずっと失敗している
そのその時やるべきことはどうなるかというと
また後回しにしなくちゃいけないんです
3時でやらなくてはいけないことは 4時半にすると
4時半にやらなくちゃいけないことはどうしますかね
そうするとやり残した仕事というのはどれぐらい溜まるかと思いますかね
だからどんな人間でも
死ぬ時はすごく気分良く穏やかに死なないんですよ
やり残したことっていうのはあまりにもあって
やったことっていうのはほんのわずかなんです
それはまた心にすごいインパクトになるんですよ
無明の基層に だから宿題やらなかった子供たちは学校でまた止まって
みんな下校しているのに宿題やらせる場合は昔はありましたけど
今はわかりませんですけどね
そういう感じでもう一度やる羽目になるんですよ
輪廻っていうのはそういう風に起こるもんですよ
もう一度スタートからやってくださいと
でも同じことだから その時も
もう一度生まれても もう同じやり方で後回しにする
で そういうことで決して終わらない終わりがないように
この人間の苦しみっていうのは続くようになっているんです
これは心の働きはそういうふうな働きで
そこをそのことを言ってるんですよ
お釈迦様は そこでアッパマーダっていうのは
やるべきことをやらないで怠って後回しにする
パマーダっていうのはアッパマーダっていうのは
やるべきことを淡々とやる人
その人はこの競争で勝ちますと
生きるということに勝つためには
この観察するヴィパッサナーをするという作業をするしか方法ないんです
はっきりと何をさせるかというと
ただ今の瞬間というその瞬間を観察してみる
そこで発見できますね
微妙に瞬間瞬間で物事変わっていく
これ一つにすっと絞って集中して観察すると
その現象が自分の体の中でね
認識の現象を観察してみると
まあ見るものでも聞くものでも何でもいいんです
すーっと変わっていくんだと
固定した実体した変わらない何かあるわけじゃないっていうことは見えてくるんです
そう見えることが智慧と言うんですよ
智慧が現れると基礎が結構ダメージを受けるんです
それでこの基礎自体はまあ壊れていくんです
3回で壊れる  4回で壊れます
だから悟りには 4つあります
で 基礎を壊れたらもう二度とあの変な貪瞋痴のものっていうのは出てこないんです
それで悪循環は終了するということになるんです
まあそれであのパマーダというのは
まあ後回しにするということで
これはありえないことなんです
物事は一つも後回しはできません
俗世間でも同じことで
仏教でも同じことで 二十歳でやるべきことをやらないで
40歳になってからやろうとしてもできるわけないんです
それは男性にわからないかもしれませんですけど
女性の例で考えてください
若い時は子供作らないで楽しく遊んでいて
50歳になってきて一人ぼっちになって寂しくて
では子供でも産んでみようかとか思っても無理です
もう そういうもうはっきりわかる例で考えると
もう後回しできないということはわかるんです
その時その時のことをやると
すごく人生は単純ですよ
このやっておかないで後回しにするんだから
我々はすごいストレス感じるんですね
やることはいっぱいあるのに
時間ないんだよと それが本当のことじゃない
人間で時間ないということは
無知な人に時間ないんです
後回しするんだからね
だから時間ないんですよ
3時に何かやろうと思ったとしても
やることたくさんあるんですよ
もうやらなかったことをやらなくちゃいけないんだから
だから時間が無い そうすると更にもうストレス感じて
それで焦ってやって失敗して
失敗したらまたやり直さなくちゃいけないし
それにまた時間かかっちゃうし
そういうことで生きるっていうことはもう大変なことになっているんです
全く楽っていうのは全くもない状態になっているんです
これは後回し機能だから
だから今今切りだよと
全ては一回きりだよということはわかってほしいんです
これは禅仏教でも一期一会というね
まあ言葉にしているでしょ
一期一会っていうのは
これはほとんどの日本の方々は知っている言葉なんです
全て一回きり それわかればものすごい楽々なんです
時間足らないっていうことは
あの 何といいますか まるっきり屁理屈で科学法則に逆らっていっていることです
このありえないことっていうのは
なり方ないんですよ 因果法則から見ると
我々は欲張ってあれもこれもやりたいと思っても
人間には 1 秒でどれぐらいものをできるかっていうことは決まってるんです
それが因果法則っていうことなんです
人には 図書館に入って
今日は 1時間で この図書館にある本は全部読んでみるぞと思うのはできるんだけど
これ実際には実行できないことなんです
その人が本一冊 いわゆる言葉いくつか読むためにどれぐらい時間取るかっていうことは
その人によって決まってるんだから
だから何考えたっても
1時間で読める量はもうとっくに決まってるんです
誰もそれ以上やらね やりませんし
やれませんし やったこともないんです
だから時間ないということは変な言葉なんです
全くの非科学的 非論理的
いい加減な言葉なんです
で と言った途端 その人は苦しみのどん底にいるんだよと
大失敗人生だということを表現しているんです
仏教の解釈はそういう解釈で
それぞれプログラム違いますからね
皆様方 そこは忙しいですねと言ったってもね
仏教の人にいたっても別なプログラムで解釈するんですね
失敗者である あてにならん人間やと
そういう人に何かものを頼むことを私はしませんね
本当に忙しいなのに 私はそういう人々にいろいろなことを頼むんです
普通にも本当に忙しいので
忙しいということは淡々とその時その時とことをやっているんです
それで あ その人ならこの時間でこれできるんだよとわかるんだからね
大体人間ってああ忙しいとかね
いろいろこと言ってますが
それはもう本人もわかってない言葉で
自分が失敗したっていうことなんですね
表現しているのは これ退屈だという人は何なのかね
これ無知にやられているんです
それでなんか退屈っていう人には何も頼まないでください
やってくれないんです
やったっても もう もう
やらなかった方 頼まなかった方がいいという気持ちになるんです
とんでもないことになるんです
退屈っていう人は無知なんです
退屈にならないんですよ
時間はもう流れてるんだから
だからもうバカだから
無知だから 何もやってないんですよ
これやってないということは
衝動になって心にインパクトをつけて
退屈という表現で無知の建物を作っているんです
だからやることなくて退屈でいる人に仕事を頼んでもうまくいかないんです
そういうことをわかると
うまく人生成功できますよ
誰に何を頼むべきか 誰の首を切るべきか
はっきりわかるんだから
大体会社なんか時々人の首を切っちゃいますけど
きっといけない人の首を切ったりするんです
そういうことはいくらでもありますよ
だから日本でもあるでしょう
最近ではなくて いっぱいあっちこっちで事故を起こしたでしょ
いろんなところで  [背景音楽]石油事故もありましたし
火事こそ私は去年八月スリランカにいた時でも
車でラジオ放送で 日本で何かどこかで工場で何か事故を起こしたとかね
どこかですごい大火事になったとか
もういくつか聞いていたんだから
八月いた時でも それが何なのかというと
この平気でリストラしちゃって
危機管理やらそういうのは慣れてた人々はみんなもう追い出されてるんですよ
もう年でしょうしとかね
早く退職しなさいとかね
それで四人ぐらいの首を切っちゃって
若者一人 全然仕事内容がわかってない
どうせ現代の若者だからろくなことはできない
責任感はゼロ それで火事を起こしたり事故を起こしたりして
会社には億単位で損なんです
一千万円儲かって儲かろうとしたところで
では四億円損ですよと十億円損ですよとか
あるいは事故がちょっときついんだったら
商売まで全て停止ということになるしね
そういうのはまあそっちの中で起こることで
やっぱりちゃんと物事わかるんだったらね
誰の首を切って誰を守るべきかということもわかるし
もうただ単に言葉に乗ってね
リストラだから じゃあ減らそうというね
そうもいかないんですよ
そういう俗世間の話を置いておいて
まあ物事は止まりませんし
一期一会でしょうし 人生はね
一回しかできないんですね
瞬間瞬間なんだから それを知っている人にとっては
もう人生の成功もできるし
瞑想する人には悟ることもできるということです
それで前の質問に答え出しますけど
私たちの本当の気持ちに従って生きてればどうでしょうかとということ
それで本当の気持ちって何なのかと
よく見ると出てくるのは自分に感じられるのは貪瞋痴ですよ
いろんなものが欲しいものがあって
嫌なものがあって まだわけもわからないものがあって
っていう三つしかないでしょうに
欲しくてたまらないんだから興味がある
嫌で憎しんで怒っているとも
そのことには興味がある
人がすごく嫌いになっちゃうと興味がなくなったわけじゃないんです
ものすごい興味なんです
だから忘れられないんです
そこで興味がないものに関しては無知が現象化するんです
興味があるものに関しては
怒りか欲がが現象化するんです
これが皆様の人間のどなたのでも本音です
本当の気持ちです それに従っていいのかと
それで本音を抑えて頑張ると場合はどうなるかと
その時も貪瞋痴ですよ
ただ自分の気持ちは別なんですけど
人にあれこれと言われると自分の気持ちを抑えて何とかする
それも貪瞋痴です 例えばこの人いうことをやった方が私にとっては得だよと
家庭は安心安定するんだぞと思って自分の気持ちをこらえて
例えば家のお子さんが一生懸命頑張る
それは欲ですよ 旦那と喧嘩したいし
もうぶん殴って追い出したい気持ちはあるんだけど
やらない 自分の気持ちを抑えておく
なぜかというと もう一人では自分には生活できない
子供はもうからは離れたくない
欲です だから自分の気持ちを抑えと言っても
何のことない 同じ貪瞋痴です
だから仏教は気持ちに正直になることを推薦しないし
気持ちをこらえて抑えて何かやることを推薦しない
同じやとどちらでも で
こらえる場合はこの あの
正反対の感情２つ あの
成り立ち積み重ねますから
結構ひどいんですよ 例えば旦那にすごく怒っている
何も未練を感じない できればもうぶん殴って追い出したいんですけど
もうかつては自分にとっては最高の幸せなんですね
それでこらえる その場合は
怒りの上に自分の欲が成り立っているんです
だからどちらも安定していないんですよ
それがかなりストレスになるんです
だから旦那のことをすごく好きな時は全然平気でしたけど
その時は明らかに欲だけ
旦那のことも好き 子供のことも好き
みんな好きだ その時はすごく幸せやと思ってしまうんです
怒りの場合も 怒りだけだったら誰も苦を感じないんですよ
ものすごく元気出して壊しに行くんです
人殺しに これが二重構造になるとすごい問題なんです
大体私たちに来る問題っていうのは
この二重構造で困ってて
ストレス溜まって 現代人はストレスが多いんだからあんた方の仏教でも何かないのかという
ずいぶん失礼な態度ですけど
仏教言っている 言おうとしているのはそんなもんじゃないんですよ
確かに仏教は答え持ってますけど
でもそんなもんじゃないんです
ものすごいもう信じられない
もう想像できないほどのすごい世界のことを言いたいんですね
そこがもう最終的な答えですと
ちょっとストレスなんかはなんとかなんとかしたってもね
だから私はそれぐらいは勝手にやりなさいというのはそういうわけなんです
どうったことないんだよと
時々言う 旦那のことそんなに嫌だったら追い出しちゃえばと
それでなんてことを言うんで
別に何のことない それぐらいのことなんですよ
もう だから人間が言ってるこのストレスやら精神的な問題やらね
何のこともないんです
ただ拭いただけで もういなくなるぐらいのもう単純な心ゴミですよ
大掃除なんか全然いいだ
それもできないんだからね
[背景音楽]俗世間では
それでこの自分の気持ちに従ってはいけない
自分の気持ちを殺すことも良くない
必要なこの気持ちって何なのかと淡々と客観的に観察して智慧を作り出すことなんです
智慧っていうのはもともとないんです
基礎が無明だからね この客観的に確認するということは
どんな生命でも決してやらない仕事なんです
やったことがない仕事なんです
それで決して入ったこともないものを入ると
基本的な構造が壊れるんです
簡単な例で考えてください
地球にあるどんなウイルスには我々はだいたい体慣れてるでしょ
ウイルスに 細菌に もし新しいウイルスが現れてきたらどうなるんですかね
次から次へと人が死ぬでしょ
最近入ってきたサースウイルスとかね
かなり怖かったんですね
みんな 体知らない そういうことは
知らないもの入った途端もう壊れるんです
だから不幸の塊 不幸しかない
苦しみしかない この人生構造に観察するという全くも異質的なものを入れておくと
全て壊れて幸福というものが成り立つのです
で 一般的に言えばこの貪瞋痴ですから
本当の気持ちはね これには従ってはいけない
不幸になります その代わりに不貪不瞋不痴という欲張らないこと
怒らないこと 欲張らないことといえば
わかりやすく言えば いつでも人に助け
人に何かしてあげる もらう気持ちではなくて
いつでもしてあげる 何かする気持ちになる
で むさぼりがなくなるんです
それで怒りの代わりにみんなに親切と慈しみの気持ちを育ててみる
これはわざとやらなくちゃいけないんです
本来はできない 無知の代わりに物事をよく明確に理解してやろうではないかと
これは何ですか？あれは何ですか？とか
正しいことって何なのかと知らないことはバンバン質問したりして
納得いくようにする 納得いくまでもう諦めず頑張る
そういう性格だったらストレスは溜まりません
みるみるうちに人生はすごく楽しくなっていくんです
だから答えはそういう答えなんですね
貪瞋 本来の気持ちは貪瞋痴であって
不幸を作るものですから
自分の気持ちに正直に生きてはいけません
だからって気持ちこらえて
その貪瞋痴の上に別な反対側の貪瞋痴つけてもいけてはいけません
怒りの上に欲と欲の上に怒りと乗せちゃって
これも良くない その代わりに不貪不瞋不痴というむさぼらない
怒らない 無知はしないと
そういう生き方するべきというのが仏教的な答えなんです
えーと お釈迦様の時の何かエピソードなんですけど
ある二人が出家して 仲のいい友人二人が出家したんです
で 出家してお釈迦様から瞑想を教えてもらって
修行にどこかへ出て行ったんです
大体瞑想指導っていうのは一回受けて
どこかへ行ってね 一人でやるんです
瞑想しない人にとっては
誰かが 24時間見張っておかないとやってくれないというね
ということはありますよ
それは現代社会で だからやってくれないんですよ
やらないんです 見張っておいたとしても
普通のやり方っていうのは
やり方は何なのかと聞いて
ちゃんと一人でそっとやってみる
まあ引っかかったらまたアドバイスするっていうぐらいなだけのことだ
まあそれは普通伝統的なやり方
それでこのお坊さん二人はちゃんと瞑想のやり方を教えてもらって
まああるところに行って
そこで住むところでも作って瞑想を始めたんです
まあそういう瞑想する
できるところは色々インドでも当時はありましたしね
そちらに行ったら まあ一人のお坊さんはすごいしっかり者ですね
みんなの目から見ると
早く起きて薪やら全部持ってくる
必要なもの 薪をちゃんと持ってきて
それをちゃんと整理してきちんと置いておいて
それからちゃんと水を汲んできて
そういう色々 全部入れておいて
それから掃除はきちんとやって
まあそこで暖かくして
火を作っておいて 結構暖かいし
それでちょっと疲れるでしょ
で そこら辺にまたこの子供とかね
出家しているんだから
もうシャミっていうんですけどね
で その連中とちょっと喋ったり
遊んであげたりとかね
ちょっとちょっと面倒見てあげたりとか
そういうこともちゃんとやる
もう一人のお坊さんっていうのは
もうそんなことをするよりは
もう行ってずっと瞑想している
一人だけ行って森に入って色々薪を拾ってきてるのに
この人は全然そういうことをしないで瞑想しているんです
一人のお坊さんはちゃんとシャミたちもどう元気ですか
なんとかとかね ちゃんと教えとか覚えているんでしょうかとかね
そういうもう結構そこ面倒を見ているんです
一人は別に喋ろうともしない
自分で静養している で
瞑想するお坊さんは この
あんたはね やっていることはちょっと良くないんだと
そういうことで時間を無駄にするとね
輪廻っていうのは怖いでしょうと
で お釈迦様を騙すことはできませんと
ちゃんと頑張ってるんだと
朝早く起きて薪持ってきて水をくんで
そんなことやったら 世間ではすごいしっかり頑張ってる人はいるかもしれませんだけど
お釈迦様はそんなことで騙せませんと
よく覚えておきなさいと
言っても その人は全然聞かない
この人はアドバイスは受けない人だということで
それで何も言わないことにしたんです
そこでこのお寺のことを頑張るお坊さんはもうちゃんと夜になってくるとグーグーと寝る
疲れているし あの何もしなかったお坊さんはずっと夜も必死で修行しているんですね
と そこで 2番目のお坊さんは当たり前のごとく
まあ間もないうちに悟り開くんですよ
で まあ 2番目のお坊さんはもう完全に悟り開く
それで修行の時期  3ヶ月間ですからね
まあそれを終わってお釈迦様に挨拶しに行く
挨拶したらお釈迦様がどう
まあ 2人は怠ることなく頑張りましたかと聞いたら
1番目のお坊さんはこの怠らないということはどうやって言えましょうかと
この人に対してはと悪口を言うんです
この人はお寺に入った日から何もしないで座っているか寝ているかだけでしたと
それにしたら私はもう本当に一人で全部やりましたと
朝早く起きてちゃんと薪を持ってきて
もう寒い時はちゃんと火を作って水をくんだりして
シャミたちの面倒を見てあげたりして
信者さんともそれなりに説法したり
話したりして 信者さんの気持ちも悪くならないようにすごく気をつけて
すごく忙しかったんだと
それにしたらこの人は何一つしなかったと
それに際してお釈迦様はね
あんたはね 徹底的に怠けて怠けて生活して怠けていないと言ってるんだよと
本当に真剣に怠けないで修行する人は怠けていたんだと勘違いしているんだと言ってあの偈を言ったんです
あんたは負けてるんだと
もう何て言いますか あの競争で
弱々しい馬と馬の間で
ものすごいこのサラブレッドのね
お前が走っちゃうともう瞬時に行ってしまうんでしょうし
ですから このお坊さんはもう完全に悟っているんだよということで
その偈を説いたという話で
これは物語で 一応こんなもんで十分でしょう
で それでこの俗世間であれこれやと忙しいんだからといって
仏教は全然素晴らしいと思わないんです
だいたいこのごまかす人っていうのは
結構何かをしてわざと自分が忙しくするんですよ
それは意味がないんです
ただ忙しくて焦って何かやったんだからで
それは何でも何でもないんです
だからきちんと瞬間瞬間ね
自分の情報 体に入る情報と
その情報は自分の心はどのように処理して
どのように現象化して
どんな感情を作っているかと
瞬間瞬間自分というこの組織がいかに変わっていくかと
全然一定していないということ
全くの変わるものにはもう実体あるとは言えないこと
これが私ですよというものは何もないんですよ
示すものは これが私ですよと示したものは次の瞬間でないんだから
そういうことがちゃんと理解することが本当に忙しいってことなんです
自分を観察すること ということで
じゃあまあ一応質問とかなどがあるならば聞きますか
話はそこら辺で終了します
はい はい どうぞ  音についての質問なんですけども
ここで座ってますとカラスの声ですとか
自動車の音 救急車の音
時々聞こえますけども
そういったものが聞こえた場合でも
これは音 音ということで聞き過ごしていく態度が大事だというふうにお聞きしましたけども
たまに消防車の音っていうのはありますよね
この消防車の音が聞こえてきて
この近辺の方に消防車が来て止まって
そういう状況になった場合は
聞き過ごせませんね 消防車の音がどんどんどんどん大きくなってきて
自分の家の隣あたりでパタパタ止まった
こういう状況になったら
あ 音 音なっていう風に聞き捨てられないと思うんですけど
どうでしょうか  それは瞑想する人の瞑想する時の話ですからね
どうぞ  何が輪廻するんでしょうか
だから輪廻するもの何もないんですよ
こういうプロセスなんですね
で 隅田川があると言ったら
何が隅田川ですか？と
瞬間も止まらず水が流れているので
それに隅田川と呼ぶんです
隅田川たる何かあるわけじゃないんです
だから瞬間瞬間 我々の心が変わってるんですよ
気持ちも欲も怒りもずっと変わりっぱなしで
これには止まりがない
それが輪廻というんです
止まらないということは輪廻ということなんです
何かあって どんどんどんどんピンポン球みたいに飛んでいくわけじゃないんです
そういうものあるんだったら
もうはっきりわかるはずなんです
変わらないものあるんだったら
だから今も我々の心は止まることなく回転しているでしょ
怒りがあってもすぐ怒りが消えるでしょうね
消えても別な何か現れるでしょ
だから何か消えるとその代わりに別なものが現れちゃうんです
同じものというわけでもないんです
怒ってた人が次に笑っている可能性もあるしね
だからこの次から次へと
我々の心がすっと変わっている
同じ体も変わっていく
体は地球のものだから地球に留まりますけど
まぁ心は変わりっぱなしで
心が潰されちゃうんですね
言葉で言えば心っていうことになるんですけど
心も同じものではありません
死ぬ時はもうやりきれん気持ちで死ぬんだから
また無明を通してね 基層にはすごいインパクト残ってるんだから
次の心が現れます もう一つは
外から情報なくても心の中で貪瞋痴が現れるでしょ
ものを見て欲が出たわけ普通言うでしょ
食べ物を見たところで食べたくなったとかね
その場合は目から情報が入って欲が作ったことなんですよ
しかし そういう何も情報が入らなくても
心の中で好き勝手に妄想として貪瞋痴が生まれるんですね
だから心には外から情報なくても
自分で蓄えたポテンシャルでいくらでも新しい妄想やら知識作ることはできるんです
だから死んでも死んだとは言えなくなっちゃうんです
我々は死んだというのは
ただこの体の壊れ 体が壊れたというだけの話です
物事にはストップはないんです
だから何が輪廻するのかっていうことはないんです
仏教では それに あの ナアガルジュナじゃない
ナアガルジュナじゃなくて
ナガセナお坊さんのね
説明ありますけどね で
自分でもない 他人でもないというね
ここで死ぬ人が生まれ変わりますかと聞いたら
いえいえ その人は生まれ変わりません
では別人？いえ 別人でもないんだと
どう言えばいいんですかと
ナチャソウ ナチャアンニョ
その人でもないし 他人でもないと
と答えるんですよ あの
ミリンダ王に そう答えられたらね
だったら悪いことしたっても平気でしょ
今 私はここで悪いことしたって別な奴がね
不幸になったっても知ったもんじゃないんだと
という風にこのミリンダ王はこの反論するんです
それでナガセナはあなたに例えを言いますよと
で 誰かがあなたにはもう森の中から大変美味しいマンゴーを持ってくるんだと
マンゴーっていうのはインドで一般的にある食べ物
果物です 日本語で言えばリンゴと言った方がいいかもしれませんだけどね
一応テキストにあるのはマンゴーだからね
で リンゴよりはすごく甘いんです
マンゴーは ものすごい糖度が高いんです
食べ過ぎると糖尿病になっちゃうんです
あなたにすごく美味しいマンゴーを誰か持ってきて
あんたこれ食べて あまりにも美味しいんだからね
これは種を植えて育てなさいと誰かに命令する
それであんたの あの 仕事をしてる
菜園やってる専門家たちがちゃんとこのマンゴーを植えて育てると
それでマンゴーの木 マンゴーが木になって
いっぱいマンゴー実っちゃうんです
それで通り もう 柵引っかかりの人が美しく熟しているマンゴーを見て
それを自分で取っちゃいますと
取ったところで もう警備の人々はもうその人を捕まって
これ王様のマンゴー盗んだんだと
あなたのところに連れてくる
連れてきたあんたその人に罰を与えようとする
王様のものを盗んだという
するとその人は弁解するんだと
こういう風に 王様 それは違いますと
あなたは植えたマンゴー私は食べてない
取ってもない あなたはマンゴーの種を植えたんですけど
その種はとっくに消えているんだと
私は全く別なものを取ったんだと
だから私は犯罪だと 王様のマンゴー取ったと言えませんよと
だから私は無罪ですと
王様に何の関係もないので
今のマンゴー 植えたのは別なものですからと
と言われると あなたその人は無罪にしますかと
この容疑者を 言ったら王様
いえいえ そんなことでは無罪にしませんね
だってあのマンゴー 私が種から植えたんだから現れたでしょうに
だから私のものと言えますよと
だから物事ってそんなもんだよと
こちらでいる人は瞬間瞬間変わりますけど
こちらの心の原因で別なところで別な心が現れますよと
しかし責任があるんだよと
流れの流れで だから悪いことしてはいけないんだと
という例えで このものの流れと責任ですね
それを説明しているんです
これはあの それしか私に説明できませんけど
あのいろいろ勉強している間でゆっくりと理解できると思います
できればミリンで あれ日本語訳ありますね
あの翔太さん  あります
それちょっと教えて紹介してあげてください
あの 最初のところは読みやすいんです
なんかストーリーっぽいし
ちょっと読んでみると
その 何が輪廻するのかっていう質問に答えが出ると思います
こちらももしかすると本があると思います
事務所に来るときでもね
調べて読んでみてください
他にございませんか？あ
どうぞ  時間を考えないようにする
ん？ 時間を考えないようにする具体的な方法はありますか
うーん  例えば 踏切で長い時間待ってて
もし時間を考えない方法があったら
ずっと長く待っててもイライラしないで済むんですけど
常に時間を感じてると長く待ってイライラして嫌な気分
それは自分が先を考えてるんですよ
先を考えるとすごくイライラするんです
それ結構失敗もする 先のこと考えて歩くと
どこかにこけちゃってしまう可能性もあるし
人にぶつかる可能性もあるしね
だから時間気にしてイライラする人は
いつでも今やってることではなくて
次にやることを考えてるんですよ
そういう人は大体失敗します
なぜかというと 踏切で待っている時は前のことを考えてるでしょ
そちらに行ったらそちらのことじゃなくて前のことを考えてるんですよ
だから一生そうやってこの今の仕事をやらないことになるんです
ご飯を食べてる時は出かけることを考えてもうイライラしているんです
早く出かけなくちゃと
出かける時はもう楽しく歩くんじゃなくて
もう早く駅まで行かなくちゃってことでイライラする
電車まだ電車が来ないねと
そこでまたイライラする
それで目的地に行っても
それで早く仕事終わって早く帰りたいって気持ちになるんですよ
いつでも気持ちは このポイントはポインターが将来になるんですよ
意識のポインターが そうすると影響的に苦しむんです
それからやることは中途半端でやっちゃうんです
例えば早く出かけたい人はご飯食べる時は中途半端でご飯
味もわからないし 何食ったかもわからないし
楽しくもないんです ですから
このいつでも今にポインターを
意識のポインターを今に持ってくる
踏切が止まったら 周り風景を見ながら
ここら辺どんな店があるんでしょうかとかね
そこら辺楽しむんです
電車は左から来るか 右から来るかとかね
人がいっぱい乗ってるんでしょうかとかね
見るものいっぱいあるでしょうに
何人待ってるんでしょうか？とかね
あるいは車止まってるんだったら
どんなメーカーのどんな車ですか？とかね
モデルは何なのかとかね
そうやってそこら辺はもう観察すればイライラしない
いつでも今置かれていることを見るんですよ
ご飯食べる時も 何食べてるの？これ何者ですか？見具合はよろしいですか？歯ごたえはどうですか？とかね
そうやって観察しながらやる
それで消えます うん  あ
どうぞ  今日のお話に関連しまして
忍耐をするっていうことは
どういう どういうことを仏教では忍耐をするっていうことになるんですか？ 今日は私は忍耐という言葉を使った？使ってないと思いますけど
気持ちを抑えることは
欲とか怒りとか そういう感情になる
気持ちをただ抑えるだけでは意味がないという話だったと思うんですけど
そういうことと その 忍耐をするっていうことがちょっと混同して
それは違うんですね あの
忍耐するということは
あの あの 今の瞬間に ただ今の瞬間に集中することは大変難しいんですよ
心は過去か将来に飛んじゃうんですよ
それから 貪瞋痴の無明の衝動でスルスルと生きていようとするんですよ
自分の気持ちこらえようと思っても
結局は自分の気持ちでやってるんですよ
だからそうしないで今のことを今やる
これには忍耐が必要なんですね
そう簡単ではありません
だから流れないように
感情で 淡々と今の瞬間観察しようとすること自体がすごい忍耐なんです
あの前の例で言えば 例えば消防車の音が耳に入ると
消防車や大変だという風に思いたがるのは流れなんですよ
そこで音ですと観察するときは
するためには忍耐が必要なんです
だからこの忍耐という言葉を聞いただけで
なんか尻込みしたくなるような言葉なんですけど
そういうことではありません
ただ 今の瞬間は淡々と観察することが忍耐なんです
だから 俗世間でいう気持ちを抑えることが忍耐ではなくて
やはり我慢することだからね
それでは悪い結果にはなります
例えば怒ったとしますね
怒ったらただ今の瞬間怒りがあると見ることが忍耐であって
怒ってはあかん この場合はと
それが我慢です 怒ってはあかんと踏ん張っちゃっても
もうこれはうまくいく場合もいかない場合もありますね
ただ今の瞬間 怒りがありますとちゃんと確認しちゃうと
忍耐であって怒りも消える
我慢しなくても そういう知恵の仕事なんですね
はい これぐらいのことで理解してください
はい  仏教では悪いことをするのはいいことをしろっていう風に教えてますよね
それで貪瞋痴は悪いことなわけなんですけど
あの怒りを怒らないということはそのままいいことなんですか？それともいいことでも悪いことでもないことに
そういうポジションというか
そういうものも  いや 貪瞋痴は自動的にオートモードで現れます
基礎が無明だから 悪にしているんです
で 貪瞋痴の代わりに不貪不瞋不痴が現れるように
自分がちょっと働きかけることは全部善なんです
最初に悪いことをするなっていう時は怒るなっていうことですよね
それから欲を出すなと
そういう それを実行できたっていうことはいいこと
善です  もうそのまま善
いいことをしろって そうすると
あの あんまりつのことを言ってるけど
一つのことと考えてもいいということですか
ん？わかんない  要するに
怒らないと欲 欲張らないということ自体はもういいことをしてるというふうに考えて
あの いいいいのでしょうかっていう
だから怒らないよと決めただけでもすごい善行為ですよ
私はこれから怒らないようにするそうと決めただけでも
ものすごい立派な善行為をサリプッタに書いてるでしょうに
たとえ生きてる上で失敗しても
決めただけでも大変立派ですよと
だからチャレンジすること自体が善であって
オートモードで現れる感情はすべて悪であって
もう決まってる そこで怒るのは普通
自然 やっぱり怒らんようにするそうということは自然じゃないんです
チャレンジです だからそれが善です
そうすると あの もう一度くどいようですけど
あの ブッダの教えは あの悪いことをするな
いいことをせよ 心を綺麗にせよっていうことを教えてますよね
そしたら自分が怒らないようにするということ自体は
もうつのことを同時にやってるっていうふうに考えてもいいんですか？黙々として
まあ単純な発想したら
いい悪いことはしないようにするな
こういう悪いことをしてはいけない
こういういいことをしなさい
あるいはこういうふうにして心を綺麗にしなさいっていう
あの まあ箇条書きに あの
しなくとも 単に一つ欲
欲張らないとか あるいはあの怒らないようにするということは
ブッダのそのつの教えをそのまま実行していることになるっていうふうに考えていい
いい いいんじゃないかなっていうふうに今思ってたんですけれども
まあ一応すべてをつなげていますからね
一つでスタートすればね
次から次へと他の項目も来ますけどね
すべてシステムだからね
欲がないと怒りは生まれませんし
怒りがないと欲は生まれませんしね
だから怒らないと思った人は
やがて欲も抑えないとね
実行できません 無知も抑えないと実行できません
だからこれはもう不可分離のセットなんです
しかし お釈迦様から言えば
一つだけ守ればいいと
人があまりにもしつこくくどく言うならば
お釈迦様だったら心だけ守ると
心も守ると 心は汚れないようにと
他のことは別に気にしなくてもいいと
そうすると全部守ったことになります
あるお坊さんがね お釈迦様に文句言ったんですね
お釈迦様やりきれんきんと
戒律はあるわあるわあるわ
そんな覚えられませんと
そんなたくさん 何が間違ってるかさっぱりわからないんだと
あまりにもありすぎて
もう何億もありますからね
戒律項目は もう無理やと堂々と言ったんですよ
お釈迦様もすごくその人の気持ちわかるんだからね
そうだねとかね たくさん守るの難しいね
君には では一つだけだったら
私は君に一つだけ推薦しますと言ったら
お釈迦様一つだけだったらもう命かけて守りますと
そう では君は心を守る
心は汚れないように守る
それでいい 戒律は忘れちゃおう
忘れてちょうだいと 心は汚れないように守るんだったら
お釈迦様もそういう人に認めてあげ
判子押したんだから 君は戒律を守っているようにしてあげるんだと
そのお坊さんがすごく喜んで
この人々はいっぱい守っているんだけど
私はもうなんて免除をもらったと
私にとっては楽ですと言って真面目に心守ったんですよ
それで見てみれば 一つの戒律破ってないんです
例えば与えられても与えられてないものは取ってはいけないという戒律あるでしょうに
物があると これは与えられてないんだから取ってはいけない
だから取りませんということになるでしょうね
そのお坊さんがそうじゃなくて
ものを見たら あ 美味しいな
あ これ心が汚れる これ美味しいと思っちゃうと心が汚れる
思わない それと関係ないぞ
あの戒律は  難しすぎますね
何が？ 心を守れっていうのは
あの まあ箇条書きにしてもらった方がやりやすいですね
200いくつあった方が
心を守れというよりは
でもそれでも完成はしませんよ
だから戒定慧にしているんですよ
お釈迦様が言った方法だったら
一発で完成するんです
だから守るのはたった一つだよと
自分の心だよと言ってますよ
いや 難しすぎるっていうのは
これで心が汚れるかどうかっていうのは
だから自分は心見てみれば
何か美味しいご飯見ると美味しいなと思っちゃうと
それは汚れてるでよくでしょうし
ご飯だと思っちゃえばね
心は綺麗ですよ そこでそれでも美味しいでしょうと
汚れたと思っちゃえば
これは勝手に取ったりとかね
することなくなるんですよ
ただ私が言いたいのは
なぜ難しいかっていったら
普通花を見た時に綺麗だなと思う
思うのも普通 俗世間ではそれで心が汚れたという風には思わないっていうか
そういう評価はあんまりないと思うんですけれども
やはり多分花を見て綺麗だなと思うのも心が汚れてることになると思うんですよね
そういうふうなことを考えると
心を守れっていうのはなかなか難しい
非常に難しいなというふうに思いましたのでね
むしろいっぱい戒律を守った方が優しいかなと思うし
その心を守るっていうのは
結局土台の基礎の上に建物がボコッと立たないようにするっていうことですね
立つ瞬間を常に注意して見るだけのある何か能力がないと
そのお釈迦様の言った心を守れっていう条項がうまく機能しないっていうことになるわけですから
だから能力のない人にお釈迦様は教えませんでしょうに
もう大馬鹿者だったらお釈迦様は別な方法で教えますからね
あのお坊さんは真剣 真面目で
あんまりもう私も覚えてないんですよ
何億の戒律は 覚えてないんですけど
何かしらないということでもないし
もうどんなプロよりもすぐに明確に戒律の分析
評断 評価 判断 何でもできますけどね
だから取り方ですよ だからあのお坊さんはまああんな項目なんか覚えられませんと言ったら
だったら別にいいよと
それでそのお坊さんがそれで悟り開くんだから
だから今の説明から言えば
心にこの貪瞋痴の建物が現れないようにと
ほんのちょっと注意入れておく
それだけの事ですよ それで木々の基礎は壊れてしまうんです
だから木々の基礎が貪瞋痴の建物作られるようになってるんだから
作らせないようにエネルギー出てるんだから壊れるんですよ
それでそのお釈迦様に会ったそのお坊さんはそれだけで悟りました
大体お釈迦様はあまり箇条書き
たくさん教えられたことはあまり喜んでいなかったんです
できるだけ箇条書きは少なくしたかったんです
でも次から次へと馬鹿者が出てきて
何か何か失敗するわ 何か下手をするわ
それでまた項目作るんですね
で 項目作る時 お釈迦様はすごい
なんかもう嫌だなという気持ちはわかるんですよ
これこれ禁止すると 言っても
その禁止項目もこれはあまり長持ちしないって見えるんですよ
お釈迦様だから一発で決めればいいのに
そう決めないんです その時に合わせて禁止項目を決める
決めちゃったところで
もう何日も経たないうちに訂正しなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
では訂正します これからこれこれは禁止禁止すると
これで次から次へと訂正していくんです
あるいは追加しますとかね
そこら辺かなりなんかもうどうでもいいやという感じでお釈迦様はこの戒律項目を設定しているんです
しかし 決めたら守れと
決めたものはもう命かけて守る
でなきゃ情けないと そこら辺
性格的なところは厳しい
で 人を殺す流れという戒律項目を作ったでしょ
人は殺す流れと そこであるお坊さんが友達がいて
その人は何かすごくこの病気か何かあったんですよ
末期状態で 人生は嫌で嫌で生きて生きては行きたくないと
お坊さんと喋ったとこと
お坊さんもそうですよと
こんな生きてたってね
本当にもうとんでもないと
苦しいだけやと やっぱり君が考えていることはさすが意味があるんだと
自殺したいというね 言ったらお坊さんも認めたんだから
勇気が出たんです 自殺する勇気が
それで自殺しちゃったんです
それで話になっちゃって
あの人はあのお坊さんに勇気つけられちゃって自殺したんだと
なんで出家はそんなことするんですかと
そうするとお釈迦様では戒律を訂正しますと
人を殺すことも 人が自殺するように
何て言いますか 説得することも禁止します
それはもう人殺しの項目にそれも入れたんです
いわゆる殺すことも禁止
死んだ方がいいやという言葉も禁止です
そういう風にもう次から次へと訂正していくんです
まあ最初からおそらくそれも考えて考えておけばよかったのに
それはしませんと いわゆるケースが現れない限りは
戒律項目は設定しませんという立場なんです
ケースが出たらすぐ変える
法律は変えます 法律っていうのはそんなもんです
いい加減なもんです そのその場合は変えればいいんです
それがスリランカ人がえらい真面目に受けてるんです
スリランカの国の法律なんかはわかったもんじゃないんです
今日ダメというのも 明日になったらあれあれ変えましたと
もう法律変わるというもののスピードはもうついていけない
あらゆるものってもうほとんどもうもう三ヶ月そういうのやってくるともう変わってます
これ困ったもんですけど
まあまあそれは政治家だからね
自分の都合のいい法律はもうイギリス時代のものはそのままあるしね
まあ自分が損するんだったら
次から次へと法律は変えたりするしね
そういういい加減ですけどね
とにかく変わります だから私も一年一回国へ行く場合は
すっごく微妙にそこら辺チェックするんです
今日の法律は何なのかと
でないとまあもういろいろ言われます
で 公務員の人々っていうのは
これ決まり守るにはもうかなりできていて
えらい厳しいんです ものすごいちょっとでも間違ったら全くもう容赦はしないんですよ
あの連中は それがややこしいんだから
私のやり方はこういうこういうことをしたいんですけど
何か方法でもないんですかと
言うと あちらはもう次から次へと法律知ってるんだから
ああ それでお坊さん じゃあこういう風にしたら大丈夫ですよって言ってやってくれるんです
表面的な法律では禁止ですけど
いろいろまたありますと
抜け道は 抜け道自分で探してやろうとしちゃうと終わり
もうものすごい厳しい
一回こちらから送った品物っていうのは
この頼んだ人が資料間違っちゃって没収されちゃったんです
これは不法的に輸入したんだと
不法でもなんでもないんですけどね
でも人の間違いと言ったっても
これはもう送ったのは私ですから
私は責任取らなきゃいけない
私はある会社に頼んであって
会社に行ってあれどうなってるんでしょうか？と言ったら
あれはとりあえずあれは没収されましたと
没収したという それでどうなってるんで
それ一旦没収したら国のものだから
大統領の直接命令でないと返すことはできませんということだ
言って資料をくれたんです
没収したっていう で これ命令出したの誰ですか？って言ったら何々さんですと
この管理の はい わかりましたと言って
その人の会ったことも何もないんです
官僚の一応上の人ですけど
名前だけ覚えておいて
で そこら辺立ち入りも禁止
一般人にはもうパスないと
言って で こういう人に会いたいんだと
でもこれ入りません 普通はね
人に個人的に会いたいと言えば
もう会わせないわけにはいきませんだから
でお坊さん来て 何々さんに偉い人でしょうし
会いたいんだからみんなあちこち話しちゃって
もういいですよということの中にれちゃったんです
中に入れたらもうそこでパス持ってる人々ももう百人ぐらい待っていたんです
その人が何か会議があって終わってくるまで
終わったら まあそういうこういうことなんで
これ没収はっても 実はこれ私の品物なんですけど
で どうしましょうかと
はいはい わかりました
何のこともなく自分が出した命令
自分で大丈夫だと取り消せばそれだけのことだから
ったらこのはい また会社に行ってくださいと
そう言ったっても 「でもこれわからなくなっちゃうんでしょう」と 「
私にも来られません」と 「
いや あんた来なくていい
その人に頼んでください」と 「
普通のルートで資料書いて出せばまた出します」と
ただ それに税金払わなくちゃいけないんですね
私はまあ税金も前だったら払うんですよ
私はいなかったんだから
あの会社あれ取るでしょ
私は実は私は今来てるんだから
私にはいくらかの税金の免除があります 「
あ そうです じゃあパスポート一緒に送ってください 」
それだけ免税でもらっちゃったんです
大統領命令がなければできないっていうことはね
税金も払わずに 税金も罰金も払わずに
だから まあちょっとやり方次第でね
これむちゃくちゃ法律あるんだから
まあすごい簡単です 同じ手段は日本でも時々使いますけどね
まあとにかく法律っていうのはどうったことはないんですよ
人間がその時その時 その
その都合に応じて作るものだから
あんまりどうったことはない
しかし 決めた法律はすごい厳密に守らなくちゃいけない
だからといって法律のために死ぬ必要はないんです
都合が悪ければ法律を変えるしかないんです
そういうところで 仏教は国の法律に対しても
ブッダの法律に対しても
そういうアプローチなんです
国の法律も我々は破ってはいけないんですし
その場合は国で裁かれるでしょうし
それでは終わらないんですね
戒律にも入っちゃうんですね
で カトリック教徒は違うんだよ
カトリック教は自分たちは法律とは関係ないという立場取ってますけどね
これで結構やってますよ
いろんな悪いことして全然もうバレること見つかることもなく逃げたりしてね
あんまりにも犯罪起こしちゃうと
まあ政府は黙ってられませんからね
まあ捕まったりしますけど
それでも難しいんですよ
仏教の場合は仏教は守ってあげない
法律破っても 破ったら
嘘を言ってもいけないでしょうし
まあとにかく戒律項目はたくさん出たんです
出たっていうことは このいろいろケースが現れちゃったからなんです
それで質問なければ  よろしいですか
はい  四念処の「智」っていうのがよくわからないんですけれども
どういうふうに考えるんですか
いろいろ説明してたでしょ
智の説明はいっぱい  じゃあこういう風に
例えば何か見たら 「あ
すごい超面白い」と思ったら欲でしょ
分かりますね 「なんだこれ嫌だな」と思ったら怒りでしょ 「
なんだこれ つまらない」という場合
無知です 無知が蓄積するとすごく退屈になるんです
怒りか欲が蓄積すると退屈になりません
そういうところで聞かせてください
はい よろしいでしょうか
今やるべきこと 現在やるべきことをやりなさいというお話をされてて
やるべきことっていうことにすごく関心があるんですけども
やるべきことっていうことに
やる行為の内容とその行為を観察するっていう 2種類の作用にお話が引っかわせていただいたんですが
その常に観察するというやるべきことっていうのは分かったんですけど
そのやる行為の部分ですけど
それも結構貪瞋痴で考えてしまうので
やるべきこととやらないべきことを見分けるというのが難しいなと思うんですが
その辺はどう考えたらいいのか
貪瞋痴の場合はいつでも選択いくつかあるんですよ
悪いことの場合は 良いことの場合は選択 1つしかないんです
例えば自分が怒ったりするね
これ悪いことでしょ 仏は仏教では怒ってはいけないんだからね
怒った場合は怒ったまんまでいるか
一言葉言うか あるいはそいつを殴るかとかいろいろ選択が出てくるんですよ
ということはもう悪ですね
結局は 怒らないということの場合は
たった一つ やるかやらないかという曖昧さがないんです
だから今やるべきことはこれという風にはっきりする場合は
それは悪にはなりません
選択肢が複数あったら
それはもう悪ですね うん
これしかないという感じだったら正しい
それが思い込みの場合もありますよね
まあまあ それは俗世間ではね
まあ完璧にはいきませんから
まあだからね 別に修行の世界で修行してしっかり心直さないと
まあ生きてる間ではもう全部やっぱり混ぜてます
思い込みもあるし 勘違いもあるし
いろんなものが起こります
判断基準の目安としては
複数選択肢があるかないかで
そうそうそう うん いろいろ具体的な例で言えば
例えば人が倒れそうになっている
手を出すぐらいは当たり前でしょうに
手を出そうかな 倒れるまで待ってみようかなというと
もう悪ですよ ということは
もともと手を出したくないというね
勝手にしろという気持ちでいるんです
あの気持ちだからもういろいろ選択が見えてくるんです
大体選択維持がいろいろごちゃごちゃごちゃ出てくると
もうもうもう悪ですよ
元は悪です 良いことの場合はもう全然疑問が出てこないんです
例えば私はよく言う場合
全ての生命に対して慈しみを育てなさいと
そうすると疑問が出てきますよ
では 悪い人に対してはあんたどう思いますかと
で その人には選択肢が現れてるんですよ
私にはないんです それで
その人がなぜそう分かって 2つ選択持ってくるかというと
やっぱり差別してるんですよ
心の中で悪人がいて 悪人でない人がいて
良い人がいて 悪い人がいて
人種差別 人間差別もともとしているんだから
人種差別 差別そのものが悪なんですよ
悪から 2つ牙が見えてくるんですよ
元の悪から 慈悲っていうのは無差別であるものだからね
なぜならば 慈悲でどんな生命も差別しないという
なかなか無理なことをやろうとしているんです
だから慈悲だったら悪人当たり前でしょうにってことになるんですよ
1000人に慈悲するのはこんな馬鹿にもできるんだよと
修行にならないんだと
いい人に慈悲をしたっても
だからもう悪い人にはあえてやるんだよっていう答えが出てくるんです
だから選択は一つしかないんです
そういうふうに覚えておいてください
他の方はよろしいでしょうか
でしたら ちょうど時間になりましたので
ダンパダ講義は終わりにしたいと思います
では 参拝